do you guys think that women are good at
picking men um just go around
nah
nah i would i wouldn't say say no
probably not
no i don't no definitely so so couldn't
we say that that was an advantage back
then because i think men vet other men
better than women do
because because because we just said
women aren't good at picking men right
and like every single person in the room
and the problem is like a lot of women
will go after like let's take sierra
right she'll go after future while she's
young and then and then settle down with
russell wilson russell wilson was the
husband but she went for future first
and so it's like
like i think if we had more parental
involvement in these decisions like we
maybe would be able to pick a little bit
better yeah but but you know what that
is though that's the women equivalent of
the male um wifey and [ __ ] thing okay
right tell me more about that yeah right
so basically um
men obviously tend to have a type of
woman that they want to
you know wife up quite often that woman
i don't think um
lives up to their sexual expectations
um maybe even
because she wants to be a wife and a
mother she ends up doing more of that
maybe she even not her fault becomes a
mother to him i think that happens
how isn't that your fault what do you
mean
it's not her fault that she became a
mother
well because obviously sometimes
relationships just happen and so yeah
you pick the guys you date
mm-hmm
yeah no you do pick the game yeah yeah
you do but i i still think there's
we're all living life on this weird rock
like it's not it's small okay but sorry
i interrupted you go back to so you were
talking about there's there's a wifey
and there's a [ __ ] right so so and then
they have two different
girls that they go for but i i think
something tends to happen with men more
is that at the beginning
when they're younger for example they
they might look at the girls who are a
wife you put them on pedestals oh she
looks like i i remember it when i was
younger boys would always say oh that
girl she's wifey material and they would
holler about her right yes but then i
was a stripper right and so i spent a
lot of time
sitting
with men who would come in looking for
the opposite of their blonde
there's a difference between sexual
attention and relationship attention so
i mean i got a guy again a guy will
screw a hole in the wall like i've had
guys say things about a girl where
they're like oh she was better than my
hand
and so yeah and so that's what i'm
saying so
i wish a guy would be better than my
hand
so no but no so that's not that's not
the point it's not it's not tick for tat
i'm saying like men can compartmentalize
a little bit better than women can
because they're not as picky
so so a guy can have sex with a girl
that he absolutely despises hates never
wants to see again where women typically
they have to have some sort of emotional
connection well i mean biology and
whatever
so i mean those guys were probably
talking about that girl that's like the
the one they want to marry where like
the other the other girls like they're
just trying to jack off to her no
yeah no i don't no i disagree no no no
oh yeah but this is the thing what you
have to remember is that these men fall
in love with these women i'm telling you
it is not a it is not a completely oh
your wank bank type thing
men get obsessed with [ __ ] they love
[ __ ] in fact i've seen a couple of
videos on tick tock where some man's
like men don't love slap yes they do yes
they do when you say love [ __ ] what do
you mean like was it like leave their
wife for her or just
no i mean i mean
not necessarily leave their wife but
can't leave them alone will happily
cheat on their wife for the rest of
their life with the [ __ ]
but the [ __ ] probably doesn't even want
him that's what i'm saying right because
she's in her finances doing her thing
right
so um and i'm just saying it's the same
thing with the
um with the women who go for the future
and then they go for the safe option
right it's just because realistically
there's something very animalistic about
the guy who and and probably he gives
you a better sec i i bet you that
there's better sex there so yeah i would
guess that that's probably part of it
right but but does that lead to
long-term happiness for women getting
ran through by by the few by getting ran
through by the futures in their 20s and
then settling down with that with the
russell wilson's in their 30s does that
equate to wait kind of finish so does
does that equate to longer marriages
happier marriages and does that equate
to better results so and the only reason
she's able to do that is because of the
development of birth control
well i mean look i don't think it
necessarily
um because because again again back then
like your parents were involved right
and you also had to think of if future
gives me pregnant is he gonna stick
around is it no no i do i think future's
going to do with baby mom i don't i
don't know
i don't know i don't know i thought he'd
pay i don't i don't know what he's doing
but but
but like like that's why you had to
prioritize the the beta side of
hypergamy you would you had to
prioritize like the the long-term
security over the short-term fun
before where now it's like yeah you can
have the best sex of your life but is he
going to stay and is that and if he
leaves are you going to be hurt in the
long run yeah and will that ruin your
husband a little bit for you because now
your husband has to deal with all this
trauma from your past relationships
well
i mean it's a difficult one because i've
never been married and i don't know but
my first relationship was abusive and
and he was a really really horrible guy
and i can't believe i ever fell in love
with him i feel embarrassed now right
when i look back on it i think wow
wasted my first day in my 20s like what
the hell was i doing
um but
i never felt like that before
i didn't know how to end it i couldn't
end it and then he was manipulat like he
was emotionally abusive and then he
became physically abusive then i got
into a relationship with a guy who i
would still consider the love of my life
i'm not over him and
uh yeah i bled all over him i i i had i
had all the cuts and i was just bleeding
all over him and it [ __ ] my
relationship yeah so i'm saying like you
know maybe if there's more parental
involvement you could be married by now
i mean i don't i don't know your family
i don't really want to be married i
don't think but i definitely want to be
in a strong partnership okay so i mean
maybe not marriage maybe marriage isn't
what you're looking for but but you want
a long-term partner i think most people
do right yeah so and you know maybe if
had you not had that trauma but the only
reason you could do that is because we
took out parental involvement because no
dad's going to let his daughter deal
with a dude that's abusive
yeah but how do you know that because
okay your dad can choose a man but
he won't really know the man
yeah there's been
for example arranged marriages by
parents still is yeah and
yeah till this day and
you know it's the parents that's
selecting this partner for you and
there's been women who've been murdered
abused
so so i'm curious as women why do we
always go to the extreme well because
it's the reality yeah no but but it's
not do you think the majority of men are
abusive no so so so it's an exception
i mean it's it's i'm only just stating
because
from my understanding from what you said
it's like
this doesn't happen
so that's why i stated what i said well
i'm saying there are exceptions right
but but the data is pretty clear when it
says that places that have arranged
marriages where there's more parental
involvement there tends to be longer
marriages
because because then again usually the
families would bet each other too so i
mean everyone knows who the crazy kid in
your family is right like like if
everyone has a crazy sibling if someone
someone knows they're crazy it's the
siblings we all know right and so
they're gonna find that out a little bit
better than they would where you just
meet a guy off a tinder go on a couple
dates hook up sleep together for three
years and then live together maybe call
maybe get married at the end of it maybe
get a kid and get divorced but i'm sorry
i'm sorry the problem is with that right
the no that's the number one way people
are meeting nowadays is online oh right
yeah yeah which which is terrible i hate
that i hate that fact so i think it's
the worst but
when you're talking about the families
vetting the families for the marriages
that you know
not necessarily arranged but whatever
right
you say oh they lived in longer
marriages but like